98% of non establish rioters if they
move mountains to get their script into
the marketplace 90% the time people
stopped reading after one or two scenes
I think why most scripts get rejected
after the first scene is really because
by the first page you can tell if
someone is a good writer or not you know
I had people say there's just not enough
conflict
it needs more conflict and I in my early
days thought conflict meant like people
arguing or fighting or car chases or
something like I didn't really know what
that meant exactly and so I didn't write
scripts and I didn't love movies that
were all about people constantly arguing
or fighting or car chasing right so I
thought I was writing something that was
the kind of stuff I would like but a
third party reading it said you know you
did some good things here I just felt it
needed more conflict I didn't really
know what they meant I've been teaching
at UCLA since 2007 I have brought in
countless executives producers agents
managers I always ask these people the
gatekeepers when you get a script from a
writer that's not a current client and
not an established writer or a new
writer how long do you read then decide
if you're gonna keep reading and they
always say one or two scenes I have
heard people say the first 10 pages they
were in a good mood but it's usually one
or two scenes I asked those people what
percentage of the time do you keep
reading and I have heard 1% 2% far less
than 1% and it probably averages out to
about 1% but I tried to be a little more
optimistic and I made it 2% so when I
say 98% of non established writers if
they move mountains to get their script
into the marketplace
90% of the time people stopped reading
after one or two scenes that is solely
based on what all these producers agents
and managers and what my experience was
many years ago as a reader
you got a hook an audience a reader in
the first 10 pages of your screenplay
okay you gotta hook them by the first 10
pages and I've always felt that there's
no reason why you can't hook them on the
first page but I've never read a script
where that first page was bad I think it
was bad and then the rest is actually
really great as a writer your job is to
write scripts that total strangers will
read and fall so in love with that
they're willing to go to their boss and
go to bat for you does it have a natural
flow does it make me want to turn the
pages I was just gonna read the opening
scene and go to bed and I'm like I can't
read it like why is going on keep going
to the next page actually that script
taught me a lot about writing about how
to really make an impact with each word
and sentence here's what I would say if
I read a scene of a script and it
doesn't absolutely make me want to read
the next scene I know this writer is not
going to be successful script why it's
not going to get better if you if you
your first scene is like your interviews
if someone goes to a job interview for a
job they really want they're late
they're disheveled they reek of alcohol
they're doing inappropriate jokes
they're just doing everything wrong
right you're interviewing this person
you're like okay this is this person on
their best behavior if it's not going to
carry you through then there's usually
not strong enough reason to continue
reading even if there's a great story
underneath it there's just too much else
out there that is a good story and has
the writing to back it up so it's not
that there's not something great in
there it's just that that script is not
at the level yet that it should be in
order to move forward into a film let's
say there's four scenes in act 1 what
has to happen in that last scene what's
the objective of that scene and I get
incredibly smart answers you know that's
the point of no return it's the first
crisis it's the it's the first subplot
it's the reverse I mean I get all these
really smart answers they're all wrong
but they're really smart the answer is
the
forth seen what it must do is get total
strangers to have to read v c and v seen
has to keep it read the six it's true
every scene every scene has to compel
someone to read the next scene and so
that first scene has to get someone to
read the second scene think about the
first scene as a first date you're not
getting married on that date they're not
buying your script the job of a first
date is to get a second date job of a
second date to get a third date now
enough dates in a row and then someone
will be like okay it's like I want to
get in a relationship with you that's
the moment when they're like I will read
your whole script they'll come a point
where someone will become such a fan
because they'll realize here's the
concept I know where this is going and I
think that's an awesome idea for a show
or a movie love these characters and and
these scenes are structured so tightly
and in such a compelling way I'm
starting to get confidence that this
person knows how to structure and at
some point you're like I will read this
to the end and then when you get to the
end your job is fitting the fall in love
and when they fall in love that's when
they will tell everyone about your
script it's like you're watching a TV
show that you love and no one else is
watching it you're telling all your
friends all you've got to watch the show
you got to watch the show we do that
with scripts so that's your job it's
really about it tends to be about human
curiosity a can you come up with a
puzzle can you come up with some
interesting image or some line of
dialogue or something that is puzzling
this it leaves a gap in our
understanding and makes us wonder what
the answer is all you have to do is
raise a question in the in the readers
mind on the first page and then promise
them an answer on page two okay I'll
turn the page
you know implicitly and you know you'll
get an answer and then on page two if
you get the answer but then there's
maybe a couple more questions raised and
then you want to find out and you keep
turning and then once you or you're in
there you're hooked the first ten pages
it's all about achieving that bond
with the audience and and you know
people often talk about you know people
put down a script in the first 10 pages
if it's not grabbing them and writers
tend to think oh you grabbed them by
having really exciting spectacle in the
beginning with really high stakes what
action or entertainment value which is
always helpful but to me the more
important goal in those first 10 pages
is to introduce your main character at
some length and it's some breadth and
some depth in such a way that the
audience starts to see what the key
things are that would make us care about
them what makes them a compelling
relatable person even before the main
story problem is kicked in what makes us
just kind of want to follow them you
know I mean save the cat says they save
a cat which makes us like them because
they do something self-sacrificing and
helpful that's a sort of semi joke you
know premise I think that Blake Snyder
came about just have your character save
the cat but I think what he was really
getting out was a really vital thing
that writers tend to sometimes bypass or
not understand which is give us a reason
to bond with that character before your
story really kicks in and so I probably
failed in all those and other ways in my
early scripts and maybe some later
scripts that made people go uh-huh
needs more conflict we have to have a
setup it can be very brief or a
character can be on the move so to speak
action wise they can have just arrived
in a town and we see them going or
they're going to a meeting or going to
meet with a hit man or whatever it might
be
but nonetheless it has to convey this is
who this character has been for some
time and it has to create empathy we'll
find out what happened prior to that but
the big the first big event that's going
to happen to him doesn't happen on page
1 we first have to get acquainted and
identify or empathize with this
character and that empathy must occur
immediately we have to empathize before
we start seeing what the flaws to the
character are before we start
recognizing what this inner conflict is
or what this identity is or what dark
places they might go first we have to
just connect
with them emotionally I think for me one
of the keys to real characters is
specificity I think that people are
incredibly idiosyncratic with the way
that they moved through the world
everyone has their little ticks in their
things and their preferences and so the
more of those you can throw in to a
script on to a character is gonna make
that character feel real so whenever I
see that in the script I think that's
real person because I don't know anyone
like that and that's a specific thing
that a specific person would do
that's this specific person and now I'm
gonna watch them through the rest of the
story and if those specificities fit
into a larger theme that the film or
show is exploring then even better for
me it's like there's three three things
that you do that I thought you do is
make us make us feel sorry for that
character so there's a little moments
where you can you can create a moment in
the story where a character is unjustly
abused or unjustly mistreated or
insulted or betrayed or neglected and so
it could be any character and if that
moment is there you know feel sorry for
that character at that moment takes an
instant so that's one if you show that
they're like us if we show their
humanity for example you show that they
care about something other than
themselves that's another technique so
there's a moment in the movie Leon the
professional which is about a hitman
right and it opens with him doing a hit
and he kills people you don't know if
he's good or bad but he goes home and he
takes care of a plant right and that's
right away you say oh he cares about a
plant so he's okay he's human the other
part is admiration so this is like any
any kind of you know if you're dating
somebody or you're trying to find
somebody who's a good match for you
there's that list of lists of things
that you like in a person that's
admirable trait so somebody was funny
who's responsible who's courageous as a
whole
list of things you can add to a
character to make a sale you know I
admire this usually they're like the
best at what they do
they're like the best you know the best
ad executive or the best agent the best
cop the best driver but if you do these
three things and I saw when I show clips
of the of the moment you meet the
character and is usually like a
three-minute scene you can see all these
things being applied in like three
minutes there's like you know the the
opening of wall-e after he's done with
the garbage in comes to us to his little
house it's a three minute scene and it's
about twenty of these techniques done
this is how you connect with that
character in one scene emotionally
ideally you have given the audience a
reason to side with that protagonist
which a lot of movies and scripts leave
out completely which is amazing to me
because it's one of the main ingredients
why would I as an audience care if that
character sees his father before he dies
you know there must be something that
shows me a humanity inside of that
character it can be a bad bad mafia
serial killer whatever guy but something
that I can relate to where we share our
humanity in that moment so that he
becomes the vehicle for me to discover
things about myself in the end I think
that's the secret that every audience
it's a very that's a very selfish
process I think every audience really
comes to the theater to learn something
about themselves and not about Oklahoma
or space or whatever but about their
emotions in that moment but that only
works if you can create a connection
between the protagonist and the audience
earlier so that would probably be the
formula I'm looking for is there a
connection is there a clear want which
leads to the dramatic question which is
will this protagonist successfully save
the love of his life whatever whatever
and to me conflict is synonymous with
problem so it's not that your character
has to always be in an obvious conflict
with other people and expressing and
fighting all the time or arguing it's
that they have to be in conflict with
their situation meaning they have to
have problems when
every year character doesn't have a
problem it isn't actively even
struggling against or trying to resolve
a problem the audience tends to check
out a bit right so that usually does
lead to conflicts with other characters
trying to solve a problem in life
generally leads to some interpersonal
come because a lot of problems that are
big enough for a movie that we want to
solve or big enough for a TV show our
problems that involve relations and
interactions with other people so there
will be conflict but it's not that
limited version of what I thought
conflict meant when I got that critique
so the problem not being punishing
enough which is like the letter P the
first one in the word problem in my book
was probably the first thing that I
grappled with in my own stuff of people
saying it's just not enough conflict
meaning it's not a big enough problem
it's maybe not a life-altering enough
problem which is the l word which is
about the level of the stakes of the
problem why does it matter that they
solve this problem why does the audience
care whether they solve it or not is it
big enough and is it relatable enough
which is the R word where the audience
is starting to feel like it's our
problem too we are standing in the shoes
of this character as they try to solve
this problem and we feel something about
it we want it to be solved because it's
kind of like it's us now that emotional
engagement with the character is like
the really key thing we're trying to
achieve as writers that was not easy to
achieve and sometimes writers don't
realize that things necessary to kind of
achieve that which is a lot of the kind
of relatable stuff so my first critique
of something not punishing enough was
probably also wasn't big enough stakes
why do people relate to this character
because you didn't find that sort of
universal hook that pulled people in the
character didn't have those elements
that make the audience just start to
feel like I'm bonded with them which is
such a key part for me like the
beginning of any screenplay what save
the cat calls the setup section I think
the first 10 pages it's all about
achieving that bonding with the audience
if you're having story problems all
roads lead to the hero's outer
motivation because one of the biggest
issues one of the most difficult things
for writers to really embrace is there
is this idea that it
very foundation of any story is a
visible goal that the hero wants to
cross at the end of the story they'll
get so caught up in the inner journey in
the depth or dimension of the character
or in the themes they want to deliver or
they'll just think the premise is good
so they get lost in a thicket of events
and plotting until finally they're just
coming up with new ideas and adding an
idea after idea and it becomes so
complicated and so confusing that
there's no story there if you think
about it most Hollywood movies in
particular are based on very simple
story ideas you even need to take a
story that you think is fairly complex
like Inception okay that seems pretty
complicated I had a little trouble
grasping some of that but it's very core
it's very simple
a group of people wants to penetrate a
person's dreams down to a layer where
they can change his behavior without him
knowing it that's it I was able to say
that in what five seconds and one
sentence and that everything is built on
that goal and if you have that kind of
clear through line and if when you say
what that goal is everybody gets the
same image of what achieving that goal
is then you've laid a foundation that
most scripts don't honestly have and
it's it's odd because it sounds simple
it is simple but it's not easy because I
think for those of us who writer for
storytellers we still want to get into
character we still want to get into
deeper levels of meaning we so want it
to be original and different and complex
and special that we lose sight of first
I've got to have this very simple
through line so that's the number one
thing the one of the biggest problem in
stages one and two is it doesn't lead to
a clear visible finish line that anyone
can envision whether they're reading the
script or watching the movie they know
what they're rooting for sometimes
writers confuse like internal character
arc with external problem and great
stories generally have both but the
external problem is kind of the part
that people really want to know
when they are assessing your idea it's
like the external problem has to be
really solid the internal arc is a
little more optional but you've got to
have that big external problem typically
in a commercial type project and so
that's what I'm talking about more than
the internal what the character needs to
learn and how they need to grow stuff
which is the arc or the theme or the
flaw you know that kind of stuff
sometimes we writers tend to focus a lot
on that and make that drive all of our
efforts and what I've learned is it's it
tends to be better to let that stuff
stay a little flexible until you've
gotten the sort of external problem
worked out and even kind of structured
out a bit because sometimes your sense
of what the theme is or what the
character's growth should be will change
and shift once you've really explored
the external problem the external
challenge that there you know every
scene is typically about them grappling
with and trying to resolve jumping from
the set up right to the outer motivation
in other words I think because
screenwriters are inundated with the
idea that you got to grab the reader
right away and you got to get things
going and all the abilities move fast
and so on all of that is true but it
doesn't mean you rush the story what it
means is you start building in conflict
as soon as you can but you don't rush
the story it's going to take all of act
1 to get your hair to the point where
they really begin pursuing that visible
finish line and if you start at page 10
with them pursuing the goal your your
script is going to die around page 70
because you can't sustain a single goal
that long so you've got to take the
whole stage one in stage two just to
build up to create the opportunity in
the new situation to get them oriented
to build up to the point where they have
the goal and then they take that first
step but I think that most of the
weaknesses in a narrative when it can't
hold your your attention that is because
it doesn't adhere to a certain narrative
structure if it be 3x structure of 5x
structure or whatever it is that is
ingrained in us as human beings you know
so
I work a lot with question marks for
example at what at what moment at this
moment in the script what are the
question marks that I as an audience and
burning to have answered that made me
turn the page why am i interested in
continuing this and a lot of time you'll
realize there is no question mark that
people are just having coffee right now
and you know it's a problem and that
goes back to what we're talking about
earlier which is conflict and stakes
cause drama is conflict and stakes that
also means that you don't know what the
outcome of something will be so there is
a kind of internal magnetism in a
structure from moment to moment that I
think you have a it's very easy to get a
good feeling for that and to not be
distracted by I'm always after the
moments that don't live up to their full
potential in what they are trying to do
and that's a very abstract thing that's
it doesn't matter if that happens on a
boat or in space or on a whatever it's
you know it's always the why should the
audience be at the edge on the edge of
their seat right now what are they
wondering about what do they want to
find out why do they care what do they
identify with those things you know so
it's almost a mathematical structure
which helps Muller because it is
basically more or less to start the same
starting point for almost every script
which of course a lot of writers hate
because they collect but my script is
different from there that's good it is
different in subject matter and content
but in the underlying audience
expectation and the rhythm than ideon
says in consuming a story it's not
different it's gets me that's met with
the same expectations so you have to see
it through that lens to know how an
audience is going to react to it I think
the only way to reach your full
potential as a creative person well this
would be true of anyone but let's stay
focused with writers the only way to
reach your true potential is to express
who you really are through your writing
to be completely authentic and and know
that people will reject that and be okay
with that you have to be willing to be
rejected to be authentic and I know
because ice
a decade as the studio writer never
being authentic in my writing and I
wouldn't take any script that was close
to who I was and my agent was repeatedly
saying like you need to spec something
from your heart when I would never do
that because I was so terrified of being
rejected I knew at least if I wrote a
script that wasn't me I didn't put
myself into it if it got rejected then
my skill set my talent was being
rejected
I was terrifying to me but at least I
wasn't being rejected i if I was
offending in my writing as I as I knew I
should be and I was rejected that was
just too terrifying so you know it's
just film courage courage is so
important and I lacked it as a writer
and that's part of why I teach because I
really want to do what I can to help
inspire other people to not make that
mistake when you are your authentic self
you're going to have detractors and then
you're gonna have people that are gonna
fall in love and that's all you need is
one person to fall in love and then it
can change your life
all it needs is one person to say I'm
making this this is important and I'm
doing it so film courage writer courage
is have the courage to don't feel
protected by the rules and paradigms
find what you're trying to say create
authentic characters find the concept
and go for it and just write it
completely not worrying about being
rejected and there will be people who
reject the script but then people are
gonna see who you really are and what
your voice truly is and they're going to
be people who love it and that's how
someone launches a career in the current
marketplace